one of the ideas we're currently
experimenting with is making light
counts private for instance because we
don't want Instagram to be such a
competition we want it to be a place
where people spend more of their energy
connecting with the people that they
love and the things that they care about
Adam people live for the likes we talk
to a group of teenagers the other day
and when we mentioned that that was a
possibility I don't want to say they
freaked out but they freaked out are you
worried or concerned that that will hurt
your platform taking away the likes a
little isn't part of the fun looking at
the likes but you can still like in this
current test you just can't see the
number of likes and less it's your own
post so you don't have to do all this
social compare but we want but that's
the beauty people want yeah people will
earn it we want you to see that I got X
amount of likes on whatever it is I
posted we will do things that mean
people use Instagram less if we think
that they keep people safe or generally
create a a healthier environment I think
we have to be willing to do that even
though it could affect your bottom line
hundred percent well we do this one it
depends as per see if it works on but
I'm really passionate about us being
open to those types of changes what led
you to that particular change because
that's a big change it came out of the
team we've been focused on while being
broadly like I said it's our number one
priority
we're people too we go home we read the
newspaper we read our news online we get
the criticism and so the team that works
on likes and comments was thinking okay
how do I take some of those values this
focus on well-being this focus on the
nuance of people's experiences and apply
that to my day job and so they just came
up with this and they said hey what do
you think about this idea mm-hmm and we
were excited you liked it right away
when you heard it yeah it was a dishes